the reaction to the allegation of
systemic racism
is far more serious than the actual
presence of systemic racism
that's what's going on here let's just
take police for example you're right
about these riots
that took place in our street for four
four consecutive months
a police officer an individual police
officer was accused of murdering an
individual named george floyd
nothing more nothing less but the media
the democrats
uh and um and politicians have used this
to further their own interests the media
does it for ratings the politicians do
it
for votes because as long as you've been
convinced
13 of the population and that's the
black population
that they are oppressed that they're
persecuted by the dastardly white man
whether it's republicans donald trump or
the police they're going to get
95 or so black people to march in their
like livings
and pull that lever for the democratic
party when you look at the numbers
it paints a very different picture there
are
roughly 50 million civilian police
interactions in america every year
and a population of around 350 million
people that results into 11 million
arrests
60 000 officers are assaulted every year
and last year between 50 and 60 officers
were killed by civilians
out of all of that the police killed on
average according to the washington post
a thousand people per year 500 of them
are white
250 of them are black so the police kill
twice as many whites as they kill blacks
and the police kill more unarmed whites
every year than they kill unarmed blacks
it's that the media does not care when
an unarmed a white person is killed but
when an
armed black person is killed they act as
if it's some sort of referendum on the
police
in fact out of the 7 000 homicide
victims last year black
and that's 50 of the total homicide
victims in america
out of 13 of the population come 50 of
the homicide victims
that's roughly 7 000 black homicide
victims last year
out of that number the number of black
unarmed people killed by cops
one third of one percent
most blacks in america are killed by
other blacks just as most whites in
america when they're killed
are killed by other whites uh it is a
lie that the police are engaging in some
sort of systemic racism against black
people
it has been studied for decades there's
a very long piece
in the washington post dated
specifically april 27 2016. i know that
because that's my birthday april 27
not the 2016 part but um a long article
about the
series of tests and interviews with
officers going back over decades showing
if anything
the police are more hesitant more
reluctant to pull the trigger on a black
suspect
than a white suspect there are a group
of researchers from a university called
washington state university they've done
this experiment over decades
three different times spaced over
several years each time
same result the cops are three times
more hesitant to pull the trigger on a
black suspect than a white suspect
the number one cause of preventable
death for young whites in america
is accidents like car accidents the
number one cause of preventable death
for young blacks in america
is homicide a young black man is eight
to ten times more likely to be a victim
of a homicide
than a young white man that's why the
cops are there
it is an absolute lie that the police
are engaging in systemic racism against
against blacks and it's not just it's a
harmless lie it's a dangerous lie
because what happens
is the police pull back when they're
victims of these false accusations
it's called the the ferguson effect and
now it's called the george floyd effect
where every time one of these
high-profile shootings take place and
the cops are falsely accused of engaging
in
uh systemic racism the police pull back
and they just respond
to radio calls they don't they don't
drive around looking to be proactive why
should they they're going to put
themselves
in the middle of something they could be
accused of racism so they hail with it
crime goes up bad guys know it they're
out in the streets
and what happens is young black men are
coached
trained to believe that the police are
out to get them so when you're pulled
over and you're a young black man
instead of it being just an ordinary
police stop it escalates into something
far more serious
because you don't believe that the
officer is there to protect and serve
you believe that the officer is an enemy
so what you're doing is training young
black people
not to cooperate and therefore these
incidents escalated into something far
more deadly
virtually every one of these incidents
guys whether it's eric gardner in new
york
or um michael brown in ferguson
or george floyd in minneapolis or jacob
lake in atlanta virtually every one of
these things would have been avoided
had the young black men simply comply
and if they felt that they were
mistreated get a name get a badge number
and resolve it later on
instead the so-called leaders including
joe biden are throwing gasoline on all
of this
by by lying about what the police are
doing and making things
far far worse so the reaction to the
allegation of systemic racism gentlemen
is far far worse than the actual
presence of systemic racism